so you were both on the site
apartmenttherapy.com and they did a
feature on your beautifully decorated
tiny house and it garnered what almost
90 comments which seems to be a lot for
that site so a lot of people were very
supportive of it and one person wrote
Bravo to you both your project on
apartment therapy is one of the sanest
most charming projects to appear on the
site maybe my reaction stems from my
current sense that my partner and I need
to downsize and liberate ourselves from
the demands of larger spaces and too
many possessions I'm wondering how
common is that reaction to your tiny
home to the movement is it sort of like
someone talking about you know being a
vegetarian wear a light goes off in
there oh really how do you do that or as
you said there has been some opposition
where people don't like it for whatever
reason but is it mostly supportive that
you've received like a lot of people
they seem interested in it or or is
there some questioning involved yeah I
mean I I would say it's been maybe
seventy-five percent you know positive
just sort of the feedback that we've
gotten online and things like that um
you know and I think maybe one of our
biggest hopes for the film is that you
know just it might you know in the same
way that when we read that article 2009
the tiny house thing was kind of this
little seed in the back of my mind you
know just to kind of spark something for
someone you know no matter what
direction it takes them in that's sort
of like oh there's another option or
like oh that's really interesting or
maybe I could think about it this way
and assess them really exciting you know
and then I think you know the other
twenty-five percent is I mean there is
something about sort of like home that
really kind of reaches to the the core
of who we think we are you know and and
so I think that that does kind of um
unsubtle people a little bit when they
may be see this and they interpret it as
you know that we're saying that the way
they live is wrong or that they should
be doing this which is totally not what
we've been you know we've been pretty
careful to kind of craft our message in
a way that's that would not you know be
threatening to people but I think it is
you know
and at times threatening to people
because you know home is so attached to
our identity I think that you know our
lives with all this new technology and
then we have you know probably several
bank accounts or several checking
accounts and you have your school and
your work or whatever and you have all
these things that your life our modern
lines really are really quite
complicated and I think that you know
people perhaps feel a lot maybe at least
I know I do like sometimes feel just out
of control like I'm always forgetting
something because there's so much going
on and it's hard to balance all those
things and and then you see something
like a tiny house and it's it's a sort
of reminder of how you know life could
be perhaps like how you know Oh wouldn't
that be great to symbolize room idyllic
life style and and I think you know
that's also where the impetus behind a
lot of people wanting to downsize and
and I think it's great you know I mean
in a lot of ways it's yeah I think you
do feel like a saner person usually when
you downsize and so I think a lot of
people support comes from that like like
the pic the quote of the comment of you
that you just read um and then also
there is I think perhaps there's a
certain element of you know maybe it
calls to mind something from when you
were a child you know there's something
very kind of fairy tale issue of it that
I've notice something that's what it
because to me almost it's like you know
it's you know I could play enforcer or
something like that mm-hmm and aside
from this the general sort of you know
YouTube troll or something that bashes
things why do you think people feel
threatened because the way you've
presented the message is not in any way
sort of this dog memoir you need to do
it this way and the flip side can be
said about a larger home I mean a lot of
times a larger home won't retain its
value
with their smaller homes around it is
that sort of where people are feeling
threatened or is it they feel that
people are on the fringe that would live
in these homes and it would threaten the
quality of their neighborhoods I mean
what is this yeah I mean I think you
know there is when when you know people
have worked really hard for something
you know I think that I totally
understand how they might feel like oh
but you're saying that I've worked
really hard for this thing and I are
saying that that's not what I should
have been working for or that maybe that
wasn't worthwhile and I think you know
that we're we're not you know like I
said everyone needs to decide that for
themselves you know we're not trying to
just sort of poke holes in anyone's
lives or anything like that but i think
you know when we are presenting a lot of
options and i think that there's always
going to be a case where someone's kind
of like oh there is this other option
and rather than feeling inspired might
feel like a little bit deflated or might
feel like a little bit defensive because
of that um you know but i think i mean
at the same time that it sparks
something you know even if it if they
don't feel great about it at first you
know hopefully it sparked something that
will kind of help them you know figure
out whatever they need to figure out
yeah I think people's reactions are
almost always about their lives in like
what they have going on and it actually
is less more to you know less to do with
what we're doing and then more what it
brings up for themselves you know and I
feel like you get people who are perhaps
going through all these financial issues
who see and you're like oh that's what I
need and then they're supportive and you
see all these other people who you know
maybe just heard from somebody else that
their lifestyles wrong and then they see
us doing this project and then they're
projecting that into what we're doing
and and so I actually think a lot of the
comments are you know they say more
about the person saying than they do
about our particular project
you